okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is one of an infinite
series of meetings about language
completeness and consistency and we have
a variety of topics first topic over
right target default for copy file
yeah and that somewhat missed name
because the conversation evolved from
when this agenda item first came into
existence but so export in 12 added some
to new valve or a new value to to create
sorry override target and create archive
and extract archive are apparently
adding more values and then there's some
question of you know exactly how are
these implemented do we want to move
them to other functions etc well I mean
what's the complete inventory of file
writing functions it's pretty big we
certainly know what it is from sandbox
stuff and so on right well the sandbox
doesn't operate at the at the function
level it operates at the filesystem
level so it is command agnostic to those
things but we do have an inventory of
[Music]
functions that Devon right we came up
with an inventory of things that I mean
file convert obviously is one yeah we
have an inventory of functions that take
create intermediate directories and
overwrite target um whatever that
background noise is it because sorry I
was just getting housekeeping out of the
hotel room when when you joined a
meeting so no it should be quiet now I'm
not even gonna ask what even continent
you're on but
okay let's see so where is that list
Devin can use and that it's yeah sure
it's it's in a jurors ticket I'll try to
retrieve it oh yeah one second to say
right so then there was so this whole
conversation started from I mean there's
all kinds of stuff here I mean there's
encrypt file decrypt file there's all
kinds of things right have no idea
whether this has been consistently done
right well the could the question is and
what has it been done for because that's
a slightly orthogonal question well I
guess there's a question of and this was
a question raised by Yann I guess was
suggesting that cloud deployed cloud
publish and butchered probably yeah
absolutely it's a great idea
and then the question okay good way to
parameterize what that that behavior
right and so for right now um okay what
am I looking at here am I am I looking
at this whole thing okay um you know
okay right so that's a list of things
that currently take over a target and
for example alright this one done both
options okay yeah okay well that seems
to me to be a very inadequately short
list well I mean there is a question of
[Music]
well I mean I'm not convinced that every
single like obviously open read I don't
think open right should take an
overwrite target I mean that's a
low-level
I kind of agree right so oh you know I
think basically all right so listen
override target for cloud publishers
anybody from the
team here I mean cloud deploy cloud
published cloud export yeah yeah seems
like a good thing to have yeah for sure
and disagree I mean they functions they
already override targets by default now
and I think that should stay that way
but it would need it to have I have that
option just to make it clear so that
right and so then now is that with both
with false it will it will fail with a
message right yep mmm-hmm and what we're
thinking to change actually in the cloud
is copy file so right now if you copy
file to a cloud object
it also overrides by default but I think
we all concluded that that's wrong and
and even God how much code with that
break to change that what does copy file
do in there and the desktop does it
warned it fails and with the message the
default on the desktop is false okay so
now it should be the same what should
you do well duh I mean so first of all
keep both isn't supported everywhere and
I'm not completely convinced that we
need to do it I should rename one of
them right so so what it does an export
it on the desktop
is it keeps the name and so it the old
one is not modified and new guy gets a
space to added to at which I'm not sure
why it's a space to and not underscore
to or something more friendly like that
I think it should be a - - - and you
know and I presume if there's so if Sean
or somebody from import/export is here
because yes John is here maybe he can
speak Tosh's know pea I don't know if
there's only one of it there should be a
- - copy or something I mean if you copy
the copy it's - - copy - - copy
sure everything that implements it uses
one common utility function so I can
change it in place but what but but it
only ever makes one of it right if you
want to do this again and it was gonna
overwrite that again does it make it do
- - three noting that there's a - - - or
does it do - - - - - - yes it it changes
it two or three okay right and since
right so you're repeatedly giving it the
same original name so I think that
probably a new merit I mean maybe if cop
maybe we for the first one we just do -
- copy but if that's no no it's wrong
it's wrong - gosh - is fine okay
okay I'm just tracked archived append
what the heck is that meaning overwrite
target arrow append so for extract okay
if that means if some of the files exist
but oh I don't then it just extracts the
new ones mm-hmm I don't think the word
append is very good for that yeah we
chose a pen because we kind of use it in
other places to us so it's not formats
already use append for over a target
like hdf5 you can append to a file but
this is appending to the file sister ate
yeah going to me that's a much more
automatic setting for override target
that behavior by the way you sound like
you're in a cave um so so the current
behavior of extract archive or well I
guess I don't know what its default but
I suppose if you did override target
goes to false then it will fail if any
file in the archive already exists
correct and that's the default okay
right so it could be new only I would be
okay with that as automatic I mean we
haven't defined what it means for any of
these functions so I think that make it
something a very niche thing and I
almost thought that automatic would have
been the right thing for keep both I
don't think so actually
I don't think so because it's I don't
think so I think that's a very weird
behavior that I think can have its own
name automatic is sort of between true
and false I think it makes sense for
this and I think there may be other
places where that's but then automatic
is going to mean different things in
different contexts
well automatic doesn't really well I
guess automatic to the extent that it's
supported is either true or false
depending on the implementation well
isn't it the case that override target
to true an extract archive will rewrite
every file correct so I I you know I
have to say I think automatic is the
intermediate case between true and false
and I think that's relevant for
directories it'll be something that will
happen regularly for copying like like
if you copy a file into a directory
automatic should mean put in the new
files but leave the other ones unchanged
see what I'm saying so that makes sense
I mean I don't think we currently
support a sort of copy file or copy
directory like that but if we did well
we should I mean and something we need
to do in the cloud sync stuff we need
that I think this is what we should do
override target to automatic means if
it's a directory worth of stuff you're
only overwriting
you're only putting in the files that
didn't already exist let's move on I
think we've got a solution here I wanted
to discuss for the cloud thing too
two things about the cloud things one is
so what these only be true false or what
these also have keep both and then what
would the behavior being keep both
because I don't think you can in general
just add a - - - why why can't just add
- - - seems reasonable to me but it's
it's a lot of cloud thingies are our uu
IDs and then it's no longer a UUID okay
hold on hold on hold on the case where
you're saying cloud publish if you say
cloud publish without a second argument
right and it generates a UUID obviously
it's gonna generate a new UID
yep if you've if you have a second
argument it's because you've specified
something to P the second argument if
you publish I don't I don't think we
even let you publish onto a UUID do you
could construct it yourself and you know
you could choose one that already exists
but I don't think we should well I think
with the new directory structure I think
we'll know if it's a UUID won't we no no
no wait a second wait a second
stop yawn can you answer that question
isn't it the case that we're putting the
new IDs and it's different base then
we're putting things which are in the
home directory and so on correct yes but
that's already the case I mean that they
don't okay well fine in that case we
could have different behavior if you try
to I mean I don't
no I don't know if you can construct so
what you're saying is if I say cloud
publish and then I give a cloud object
as the second argument right and that
cloud object is a UUID cloud object and
I say overwrite whatever target arrow
keep both right um then I think it
should know that it's a UUID and
generate another UUID adding a - - - to
the UUID is just nuts no that will be
completed theory but even generating a
new uue I'm not totally convinced why
not if it's a keep both situation I
think you want to generate a new UUID
because these functions return the place
they put things so it's not like you
lost the UUID do you see what I'm saying
hmm I think that will work fine
I mean cloud deploy on top of that UUID
with overwrite target to keep both and
it generates a new UID seems reasonable
to me
okay unreturned it to you right it's
also wonder about the other direction
and it's sort of a general problem
because we it's a port copy file from
the cloud to the local filesystem and
the other way around and so on and
there's probably other things like local
objects and so on so wonder how can we
avoid that be you know that we have some
exponential explosion of implementations
of key both for instance well it's an
orientation quiz question I don't know
the answer to that but I mean in other
words if you're doing a copy file onto a
local object I think it should be the
same deal I don't know how to recognize
a UUID local or Drupal I think there is
a way and my other nope my other
question that I didn't get that we
didn't get to is so so if we do a cloud
put then who then what about put and if
we do put then what about saving
them save and probably other things I
haven't thought of right now I think
they're okay one us youth put is a
syntactic issue about its argument
structure if I remember correctly yeah
it's not it's far Oregon right though
that thing to write is the last yeah oh
it does take options okay so I guess if
the last things are rules then it loves
them off fine okay I do believe it will
be a useful option for all of these put
save dump save all of those I think it
would be useful option okay alright
basically it's it's a you know right now
it's very kind of I don't know
old-fashioned UNIX shell like it's just
boom you put the file there no warning
no anything and I think it would be good
to have some something that has some
protection in create intermediate
directories yes I think so too I mean I
assume it does that by default right now
but I think that should be privatized
don't see why it shouldn't be and I
don't think it does I think it'll just
fail well I think could be very very
useful of it yeah actually you know what
I think I noticed that even like
yesterday I was using obsoleting export
which doesn't have this either I mean
and create intermediate directory would
be very useful an export function that I
noticed yeah here's a bizarre missing
function
okay now maybe I'm just being silly but
but if you do i've
but actually maybe this is just silly
maybe I have to use file name join and
then I say directory and then I say foo
or something does that just do the right
thing
yes it does right and you can also do a
file name expand of foo is the function
I believe you're looking for what does
that mean
finally I'm expand what or is it maybe
it's expand file name rather than right
it takes say a file name and turns it
into its absolute file name based on I
wasn't that sure but actually made me
file name join us enough I'm just oh I
see what you're saying that I see what
you're saying no no that is what I was
looking for because that is get me the
name of a file in my current directory
mm-hmm yeah so if you give it a name
with no file name component it'll give
you the name and if you want to verify
that that there's also absolute file
name which will also check that whether
or not that file exists fair enough okay
I wonder how well documented all of that
is I think it's reasonably well I mean
that those two functions reasonable ref
pages whether fair enough all right
onward right so right this was spun off
from the D experimental ization meeting
based encode and base decode and I hope
that Dorian is here because he is right
and so there was a question of all of
the various zoos of encodings I mean we
should have as many animals from that
zoo as we can easily capture we should
we should get right now so so one
question is what can we get from wxs and
so dorian do you know the answer to that
yes so there are basic Steen Bay is 85
for sure base64 five there the Hartley
sauce three maybe there is one like 35
something like this so the code is there
it's I'm I'm not sure if it's really
hooked to something like so for example
which function for example here we've
got a few mentioned here base 32 base 36
space 58 and I think there's a table
somewhere of lots of these right right
and then we have you know variants of
these right with padding without padding
sometimes there are minor alphabet
differences between page I strongly
think just like export formats that just
doing one systematic job of curating
these things and putting them all in its
super useful for the day that you need
you know base 58 with such and such a
kind living you know of padding it's
just oh it's just there I mean it's just
like it really makes things easier and
it cannot be that difficult to
parameterize these and just put a bunch
in I don't think it's our highest
priority but it seems like a good I mean
very least this is kind of a student
intern e-type project to go inventory
these things curate them and so on
well maybe curate them I'm not well I
guess the question is how far it may
just be parameters they may all just
have parameters I don't know may just be
here's the alphabet here's the mapping
boom so currently that's not how it is
implemented
doesn't mean that with some changes it
could be also currently it leaves in the
separate library like the one that we
use them for wxf okay
compress right now so there was one
question of you know could you and in
say an afternoon hook up you know base
85 and a 16 from the wxf library into
base and code and base decode or do you
think it's a bigger project than that
sorry the question is can you take that
code and hook it into base encode yeah
but yeah I think that's mmm that that's
that's not hard to get and then we may
realize that doubts of those because
obviously it was not used but providing
those versions I don't think it's yeah
as you said it's probably hard for day
of work okay well then then we can at
least have 16 and 85 and and we can
start to see okay and yeah any idea
where should expose them like a
developer function no no we're going to
add them to base encode via second
argument so the current default will be
you know base64 or something like that
because I think that is by far the most
yes that's what this fault is right and
then the other ones I think should be
quoted strings but we should also allow
the integers right because there may be
quoted string quote space 36 or whatever
but also allowed the integer 36
confusing with string 36 which is
different okay interesting so 36 means
base 36 in a different notion of base 36
right right yes so base right so so you
know base 16 encoding is different from
you know hex right because in hex you
turn it into an integer and then you
compute its value base 16 and basically
16 encoding as you split it up into
bytes
let me ask the question how do I get
percent in code
and our world that's a URL encode okay
fair enough
you encode a bit old old school so I'm
sure there are systems that still use it
what do we have these things like bin
hex and so on are they import export
formats romance No
do we support this thing I mean I'm not
sure these are exactly important I think
those are the things we should have done
30 years ago for Ben hex not not today
um all right well so fine I I thought I
saw a list of many more base XX formats
I put them in the chat presume ah no
that's list of numeral systems what's
something completely different
that's great yes I know that if you
scroll down there
type of notation
no that's not the same thing right that
this is not base base encoding well
actually I mean that's base form but
that's not including that's something
way bizarrely different I mean that's
not ice and they are mixing they're both
totally confused that totally confused
here
Wow confusion out on the interwebs
shocking no this is very very confused
unless people are using something like
that
I'm very confused here
very well that no that's a real one
that's a real one base 32 it's a real
one but these are the ones are just not
real ones are they 50 base 62 encoding
what the heck no this is totally
confused
well okay that's it a different thing I
mean that's that's the use of different
letters to represent the high order bits
I mean as you say if I say integer
string 64 that's something completely
different from basin code because
integer string of basics before
yesterday you have to say basic C 4 here
I can say base 64 yes what the heck is
that
well that means use the base 64 alphabet
which hopefully is the same base 64
alphabet as we're using in base encode
to represent the you know this integer
written in that base 64 number system
I see and in the case of base 58 it's
the same encoding under interest ring
all right well it's the right it's
conceptually the same right so what
that's doing there it's using debate did
I believe the Bitcoin base 58 alphabet
to represent you know extend 13 you know
because we traditionally we were limited
to 36 because that's what you get from
10 Arabic numerals and 26 English
alphabet letters and so this is doing
the same thing using the alphabet
defined by those encoding wait wait wait
wait
so in addition to 36 it's adding um it's
adding 58:22 what the heck it's not
adding the whole alphabet it's not
adding the uppercase alphabet no it's
never done that and I think that would
be ambiguous right we couldn't take data
out from the world if he treated and
treated ffs
oh boy am i confused or what look at
that n it starts it it's trying to avoid
the L confusion right right I need
starts with one so once you write yeah
you really wanted end from zero to 57 in
base 58 and what's about 21 doing that
because you're in base 58 right you want
it zero to 57 so it don't miss it the
lowercase L just for entertainment value
well avoid confusion and do we something
you can read in an easier way I thought
it was to avoid back in the day
typewriters use not to have one keys
because you use the L key instead but
also it looks like it's it instead of it
doesn't have zeros or O's at least not
an uppercase o because of that confusion
right
so that's something you can't read
without confusing the genetics unless
the idea of base 58 okay so very very
different from by the way you use to
write this is right this is this is base
in the math sense in your in your fourth
grade new math sense right it's just
instead of going from 0 yeah I
understand it's got with some weird set
of digits right and the same thing would
be with four base 64 right right is
saying right the same value that they
have in the basics before encoding by
the way we should give this a can
somebody add this to the page on integer
string on the page
what's that this is on the page this
this example it should be or some
variant thereof under properties and
relations properly
might be under scope right yeah so that
last one with base64 I guess it's not
literally that but it's no that's not
but I think it's conceptually the same
okay could we could we actually put
these in because this will be very
useful to people to just see okay um
okay fine I understand what these are
now okay so by the way I would make the
argument that we should extend this 36
to 36 plus 26 and use the uppercase
letters just because it is sometimes
convenient to have that I'm making sense
yes I'm not look it's a corner case but
I've certainly needed it do you see it
you want if you do that you might as
well do the mapping yourself so exactly
the world's most difficult things to say
enter your digits and then map
everything I mean unless there's some
obvious choices around for that but I
think we should extend this because just
as a default thing it is useful to have
more you know to have the ability to
have more you know higher bases in
particular do we get to this is pathetic
arithmetic failure but we don't get to
base 64 this way yeah well I I think we
should extend out I think it's a minor
thing but I think we should extend it I
don't see any reason not to extend it it
may be convenient for some purpose okay
is there any more to discuss with this
other than the desire to add these other
standard basis to base in code
yes no can we go on please okay
we had a gavel we would be using it
let's go on okay so this is function
that parent so I did a sort of an
analysis of this generalized map third
function that Center or wrote which I
think
you know I think it has some you know
some obvious ideas and some problematic
ideas and then I and the other section
and I have you know a couple of other
points of things we should do with map
thread okay okay right that's a rag
eater right it's an obvious
generalization it's the same list
structure in both slots that should just
work I think yeah I mean it doesn't just
work but well I mean there is a little
bit of an idea right I mean right now
does it require it doesn't require
rectangularity or does it require
rectangularity it does require a
rectangularity hmm that seems
unfortunate I mean just conforming seems
adequate I agree
okay now this case is much trickier
this next case hmm
really that I think should be in an
error well maybe a warning but it goes
ahead and does it I don't know I don't
see what the rationale is for treating
all except the longest list as Adams no
no that seems crazy okay I admit that I
think that's crazy
that's not what thread or an effect
thread just gives an error in this case
pretty sure what is thread do in this
case no throw a thread duplicates
threats only supports one level isn't
there multi multi level thread thing no
so it never has this issue of non
conforming pieces exactly
if thread is given something like it
errors out yeah but if you replace that
second one comma two with just a one no
I know will become one one to one
yeah yeah there are duplicates I agree
that with a conforming case it should
just do it the non conforming case I
guess I think it should just generate an
error mm-hmm and I don't think it's
right thing to have this shorter longer
thing going on now this one here what
about that case they're very unstable to
have one of these work right I'm
suggesting that that maybe wants to work
with with an up to spec how well stay up
to go in in the level oh oh so wait this
case is slightly different isn't it yeah
[Music]
I was so pleased today to find out the
graphics know the partition works with
up to I mean in all the confusing things
in partition honestly there is an
argument that we should put the up to
case right in here
do we should put it right there
to help people who otherwise are going
to be lost dealing with nob values and
things in partition any comments from
people think that that adding a ninth or
is it a tenth no but I'm suggesting that
we put in a second element here because
these two cases are very common right
and the case of up to here partition of
lists up to n is super common by the
time you're down in this noise here you
know those are much less common now this
gonna say some of those later ones could
even be removed and handled via table
later in the notes yeah I don't like
that very much but I know this is a look
ultimately this function should get
options like padding options I don't
know whether are there padding options
that could be reused from from image
busing and so on but we could give us an
alternative to this argument structure I
don't think there are enough well but
there may not be enough for everything
but they were just being able to say
padding arrow whatever and cyclic error
or whatever I mean the full
specification here is useful it's not
like anything here is absolutely useless
it's just hard to understand
mm-hmm and if you need it you need it
but you know the up to case the
partition with an up to just seems super
commonly useful and I would favor
putting it right in here
discussion maybe somebody could look
into that and see whether it makes sense
the very least we could have it in one
of the first examples here I'm a bit
surprised it's not in what we put in as
a fourth basic example yeah I totally
support putting it in a it possibly even
as a second basic example now the offset
is really useful okay but yeah I mean
and also the offset is it confuses you
because the up to doesn't isn't relevant
when there's an offset there of one
right I put it down here and the only
other case that I might put in here the
only other thing that is important is
the cyclic case but the cyclic case is
already very complicated because you
have to say where and the cycle you
start and so on
I assume by the way that the cycles
construct that we introduced for
permutations can't be reused in any way
here it's something completely different
that's because the cycles in the in
partition is there pausing we're here
it's more like the position they would
be no no but it isn't it's it's the
position here as well
because what you're doing is you're
saying does it start with ABC or does it
start with BC you know it's you're
taking this necklace basically that is
your original list and you're somehow
I'm not sure well it would be a
generalization of what partition does
because partition currently it's like
it's creating a great if you are great
of these cyclic things and then it's
very salty yeah right we could rotate
that great with cycles as presentations
that's pretty obscure yes all right okay
okay anyway we agreed at least we're
gonna put up an example down here can
somebody do that yeah
seven just you know create a ticket so I
don't forget Kevin oh yes yeah I'll make
it tickets okay
back to this all right so what's the
question here the question is an up to
here right so this is what happens if
you have conforming but sort of not
equally deep things right so it's this
is sort of like the first example only
there isn't an inner list but wait it
says at level n it's not down to level
and it's at level n oh I suit you say
you're saying go down to a level of it
most - right it could be higher than -
right so if you look at the exact right
there isn't the level to sort in the
second spot but there is right this
example this example here now the
example the example below this example
yes right I'm missing a list in the
second in each of the see don't have a
list around them so literally I can't go
down to - right and you'll know that the
generalized map thread added an extra
list around the result of F of 3 C which
i think is wrong that's odd
yeah I thought right so this I think
might you know maybe this should be an
error but if you say up to of 2 then
well if you don't have two levels you do
it at whatever is the deepest level you
have right so they're taking things as
atoms basically that would otherwise be
be burrowed in - yeah sounds sensible to
me mm-hmm ok what are these other things
here all right
oh gosh Association right so so well I
mean is so right so there's the one
thing which is sort of a more
specialized thing that
you know for Hosea is super useful we
may or may not want to put it in our
Matt thread which is counting levels
from the inside and then is that you so
far specifically I use it it's it's a
key idea inside quantity array
it's a via that allows us to avoid
repeating the units of internal blocks
lots of times because it's reading to
the internal structure of their rights
I see right so rather than following the
repetition at the top level is following
the repetition at the inner level I
think I understand I mean but you know
for quantity regular now all those
things are numbers right it doesn't
matter really I mean we could have a
quantity array in which all the
magnitudes are symbols yeah okay but it
doesn't appear frequent it's just that
in quantity array this is an important
of the answer
I suggest we do attack right then the
the other one is the bigger issue so
right now we have and this is probably a
history you know as historical accident
of them of implementation but we have
the following sort of crazy behavior in
the second argument level zero must be a
list or it can be a sparse array not a
other kind of array but it can be a
sparse or a level one must be a list
where a sparse array or an association
and then level two and deeper can be
arbitrary so we might want to have in
allowed heads or we might want to just
sort of you know well I mean this is
very entertaining but it's completely
insane this inconsistency between these
things
what do you mean consistency
inconsistency oh yes right and so the
thing with the background color is sort
of the fundamental
identity of map threat that was a and I
came up with so map thread is you move
if you give it a depth and you move the
outermost level and levels in and then
you map or sorry you apply F at that
level so you rotate the first n
dimensions and then you apply so there's
no and and Association as you know as
kind of funky as it looks is actually
following the same identity to the
extent that transpose implements allowed
heads which it currently does a pretty
bad job of which is why it's not
documented and so right so the question
but it certainly does seem like we
should allow maybe we were at level zero
we still require a list but it certainly
makes sense that we could allow any head
at level one and deeper well why aren't
we aligned that at level I mean I
understand why we're not allowing it
like an association at the very highest
level am i confused I mean why isn't
this case here like if you say well uh
that I mean I what I was thinking was
something like map thread F onto the
Association a goes to list one to B goes
to three four
now why isn't that worse what did that
do and I'm so confused here absurd would
take I see what your concern is how do
you take 1 1 3 the hell would you do
that right so I have that basically
right so it should be F of of a couple
of associations is basically is what I
say right above right because the when
you you transpose
oh hold on that was at level 0 so at
level 1 it should be an association with
key right so right so I guess we can
figure out what I should say right you
should transpose that and right so my
argument is that it should basically be
the same as what you have in that in the
mini what I have in to manipulate there
so if you did that if you clicked on the
one to make it at level 1 that should be
the result because I was the C coming
from oh well that's because I had oh I I
had a deeper level there top level
Association here yeah so what did I
saying is that your first transpose so
the list gets outside the Association
gets inside and then you mark inside
sorry apply F inside so the Association
disappears the red will be then least F
1 3 F 2 for exactly what you have in the
prison no no I understand you have to
specify it out that's all I think will
do what you want
and now a Scrabble add that what is that
doing that's applying so that each one
of those yet at level one and it's
saying take that so the knife that that
does that but then I'm saying F apply to
this mm-hmm the key idea here is that
map thread contains I apply so it's
going it's going to destroy a head at
one level and in some cases if we have
this association it will destroy it
precisely the head Association so the
keys disappear
okay so we're thinking of an association
I have to say I would not have
immediately guessed that that would work
yeah that's actually documented or just
an empirical observation of how apply
works on associations I think this is
correct because the head Association
must disappear so once the Association
hai disappears the keys cannot be there
yeah I understand that
all right I don't think we really need
to well
other than knowing that order matters
but this one I'm just sort of proud of
so we should look at the fancy ones
right so it's sort of illustrating this
this principle right so you have the
array dimensions then as you change the
level you see how you've moved the you
know move to for two positions three
positions etc and then you apply at that
level to get the F and yes
so that and you
do it at four because then you'd need to
be able to move forward the the four or
four positions out and there aren't four
positions to push it in so this was very
helpful to me in understanding what was
going on I don't know nice alright so
the conclusion here is we probably
should allow any head and I'm not and
then the question is what happens when
we do that and I think we're only two
using an allowed hats mechanism well we
could also do that and then the question
is what what exactly does that mean
right it could right does that mean does
that apply it all levels at all levels
that are being moved around it probably
doesn't matter what it does for things
beyond where you push but then there's a
question of you know list of things I
mean I think we definitely should allow
list of things which are not list as
long as they're consistent because I
think that's certainly something people
want right you have your collection of
foo object and you want to map thread
and that currently you have to you know
apply lists before you stick it into map
thread in order to map thread and it
would be nice if you could just take
your list of food objects whether you
really if we really need to allow level
zero
I don't know and I'm sort of reserving
judgment until I see what happens once
we find all right yeah yeah all right
should we move on yep okay table
generalization right so this is an
example you know just of Python of the
sort of thing and I understand that
there's a let me make a general point
yeah the one of the things that we don't
have because of 30 years of history or
whatever
um you know one might have a construct
for each bah-bah-bah
you know I in such-and-such mm-hmm list
and then what would it look like I mean
it'll it's very much an expert thing
here alright so this is in fact
equivalent through our table exper I
list you know the fact is that it is
very syntactically nice in you know in
code to be able to see something that
reads more like this mm-hmm
I mean it's very very similar to this
but but I'm just wondering whether
there's anything useful we could get but
it's not it's not just table it's due
right and I don't and I don't see any
semantic difference between do and for
each and so I was just wondering if
instead of that instead of I comma list
you had I common you know K comma V or
maybe rule K goes to V could that just
work all right isn't that Santa's
proposal I think so yeah so so my my
opposition has softens some since I
first wrote this because I discovered
that table even though this is
completely undocumented apparently table
does allow you to use an association in
place of list really yeah would have
been you didn't know that so now I don't
feel bad about not knowing that so is
that just the central dogma oh do I need
to hit you do I need to send you to
South Africa but right but it currently
throws away the key right exactly so so
that's why I was suggesting that the
syntax of the I there
in order to indicate whether or not the
key should be thrown out so what is it
gonna do here it's going to give you the
list
oh that's just totally crazy that's just
totally crazy well it's the central
dogma it's tree it's treating that
Association as the list of values well I
think that's how it's that different
from a high of F throwing away the keys
applying F to an association throwing
away because it chopped the head off
whereas this anything that eats our
Association makes sense to only take the
buttons you know and is you you have a
way to tell everything well I understand
I mean but but in this case for example
if I say map over that association it'll
do that and that's what I would have
expected the table to do no [ __ ] it
it's it's still the central dogma
because the point is that it kept the
key oh I see so you wanted a goes to f1
and so I want and if he goes to F of 2
right but they go shallows always return
ah at least right so I think that will
change too much stay with me yeah I
could see that
right and I guess that that's the other
question what does the if we do well
that's the in in the Clery the table
must always return a list which I agree
doesn't seem like a foolish theory
that's completely blown up by having
well let's see if I did okay so if I say
Association map F a B really I get that
right and then let me be clear my mind
my objection isn't to the functionality
like if we have an association table I'm
all for that I'm concerned about
sticking this into table because you
know well this was before I was a
strongly opposed before I knew it
currently accepted associations but even
then you know if even if we're using
both the keys and the values I think
okay that's a return okay the list
because we can't guarantee that what if
we introduced a new function that is
that is the equivalent of that is some
syntax foo and I don't know whether it's
I don't know what the right way to do
this is and I don't know whether you
need multiple you know if you just do a
one-dimensional case of this what about
the two-dimensional case what about the
the Association of associations or the
or I mean okay so I could imagine
something that goes something like for
each I in
the term for each is right I list and
then a level here and what that does is
it's the equivalent of map
except what it does it takes expo and
for every I so let's say I say for each
I don't think but um for each is right
here but let's say that was I squared
stop here all right let me try it let me
try something let me try something here
let's say for each I squared plus j IJ
and then a list you know like this well
we don't actually need the level because
we know the level because these are
symbols right and in other words this is
a transposed version of a table like
construction I mean it's it's a
combination it's table meets map so the
last leg many stuff doubles yes in that
case it's a list of IJ forms so for
example if I were to say for each I
squared I come with this then it will be
fed ABCD okay so let's see what happens
with associations with this construct um
let's see so here if that's an
association so then we're saying so
what's the issue here so we need the
both the key and the value is that the
idea yep so let's say it's I squared
I'm confused so then what we want to do
is let's say it's key to the power value
and then the very bizarre construct
would be something like this and then we
would have an association here but then
the
we might have is that this is just a V
for value and then it would iterate like
a list over the Association and this
would return this would return an
association this would return an
association as well but in this case it
was only a function of the value
and so it keeps the the keys unaltered
yeah I would assume so in that case yes
well in both cases oh yeah no no no it
but in one case it's depending on the
key but in the other case it's not right
but but in the result in the resulting
association the keys are the same as
they were before
yeah you know I really like this this
multi I hadn't thought of this
multi-level construct for this what
would we call this thing yeah I mean I
would be fine with calling this for each
other than I would want our argument
structure to be you know transposed or
rotated I guess right that's for a table
were you supposed to know you're saying
i J it's different because you are
scanning them one by sorry so stillness
approaches inner you are taking an out
of there I think so I would think did a
lot of my yeah okay so this would say
for each it's a little weird that this
has the evaluation semantics this will
be totally weird because it would
evaluate its second argument but not its
first and third argument mmm
so we'll be a halt last and hold first
and would it also return something of
course it would return it would return
the result the the table like result
yeah which is what I find surprising
from other languages to be honest
exactly for thinking about for in
Wolfram language okay well so maybe the
name isn't right the functionality IO
seems useful oh yeah sure
does it not return nothing in these
other languages no cuz it's a for loop
it's it's syntactic sugar for a more
complicated for loop
guess the point is that here this is
generally generalizing the iterator
language so we will end up with the
various consumers of the iterator some
products but this isn't an iterator I
mean this isn't this is not an iterator
this is right no but we could write it
imagine that instead of least a comma
list we had least least common list so
we could incorporate this in the
iterator language and then it will work
in pole yes so imagine table of
expression least least comma I comma J
how I should say
IJ you're destroying my poor function
again but I agree that's a nice syntax
that will be a useful syntax to have I'm
amazed that in 30 years we haven't
thought of having that syntax before
seems obviously useful sorry the
advantage of these which is also more
work is that it will work in tables some
product exactly right but I still think
it's useful to have the syntactic
simplicity of something
you know well you don't like the wood
for you don't mind each
you know I think that's the think that's
my sense of the objections as well
my problem with for each is that it
sounds very close to for all that's just
because you know what for all is I agree
I mean but okay but the functionality so
let's look at the functionality again
for a second if that was the order right
I mean it's kind of stupid because it's
basically it's just saving you one list
bracket but it's a very elementary use
right so if we implemented this in in in
the core iterator stuff so it also
worked didn't do and your for each guy
would be right so table could do well I
guess a bigger question is return values
right and what if you want to return an
association yeah exactly and the whole
point here is that in the for each
construct you know again if this thing
well we this apparently already works
the know the list thing we met that
doesn't return an association there
which I find very bizarre but that
doesn't return an association I think I
think it's fine because in the same way
that some needs to return something plus
effectively stable needs all right well
then that's a good reason look the main
point let me let me make a very
practical point so like in my elementary
introduction book okay I do not
introduce map okay the idea of map like
constructs is useful but in a sense this
function avoids anybody having to know
about pure functions right in other
words you could say if you did this if
you said you know for each
um you know a list of images I'm now
getting this the wrong way around you
know I'm saying for each blur and image
images yeah I mean the list of images
you know as you you're right to say that
that's basically a table but I don't
think people use the table that table
syntax very often and I think it'd be
much better if there was a single word
there the Memphis because I think this
is a very common construct admittedly
for probably more elementary programmers
I think that as soon as you get
seriously into functional programming
you're not going to want to do this I
mean I think people might use table with
the list you know iterator more than you
think precisely to avoid having to
introduce no I understand that but like
for example in the IWR book I made the
decision to not talk about that table
thing because I thought it was kind of a
weird you'd have to explain that syntax
for something that is I think a very
common type of operation is sort of
embarrassing mm-hmm so my question here
is and I mean with this thing the
semantics of Association could be quite
different so the question is what would
you call this if it was expert I list
right know except for the fact that the
semantics of the variable are different
that's the whole point the whole point
is unfortunately you know our typical
semantics like for I don't know plot or
anything else it's like we go okay
what's an example of a function that has
I think this is unusual semantics for us
you call it evaluate for or something
like that that's extremely obscure the
notion of evaluate I mean the the each
is a really nice concept right yes
that's right okay look for each what
would do that look basically the writing
is for each I in blah I mean this is
really set construct or set build rate
right it's not for each I in blah this
is X such that this is f of X such that
X element list right I mean if you want
to say this accurately right this is
this is open brace expert achill bar
alpha set right but but this is
returning a set right no it's returning
an ordered sequence okay fine but to the
extent that we represents a spot by
lists in the Wolfram language I I know I
know I know that that's the the problem
is that without an intermediate key word
that for each doesn't make a lot of
sense
Brian our livestream is suggesting with
each but I don't think that really helps
us I mean I agree that you know what I'm
doing it you know thinking about it
something like this but that is so
frigging Buzard well that's obviously
I'll accept because it's just way wrong
level
by the way Ethan I'll live streamis
talking about key value map indexed I
wish we had a general way to refer to in
a map right if we have hash one you know
hash two etc Tara Tara I wish we had a
way to refer to you know hash hmm
picking a weird character I don't know
hash question mark or something that
doesn't work to mean the index maybe
that's a stupid idea in other words in
other words that's a stupid idea I mean
I don't think it's inherently stupid I
mean there's certainly been cases where
you know I've jumped through hoops to
have you know I've done a table over you
know I goes to lengths of assets you
know because I needed the index and then
I had to do you know some part
extraction on the set because I needed
the element as well and right I mean
having something which says you know
what is the index
the problem is it's so obscure what that
would be I mean it's like the index
stack right at least no no no I'm not
annoying yet you use map index that it
doesn't only give you the number but the
hole is well quite
Ethan is pointing out
on our livestream I'm now confused here
Oh being able to oh that's a funky idea
being able to do full D structuring so
we got a table of expression and then to
say something like X comma Y cover lists
list of um yeah XY next x1y1 x2y2
thought thought thought okay
well and then that begs the question of
whether I mean does this I don't even
know you know what I I'm embarrassed to
say but I do not know if this works I
don't think it does if it did I'm sure I
would have used it seems to me that that
would be a nice thing to have work yep
since X y equals a be certainly works
interesting the coloring knows that
right as if it worked dresses at the
point that's a good point
well that's a good thing that would be a
good thing to get to work in my opinion
but um look I think this is an
interesting idea which probably should
be made to work how can I put in an
extra level of lists around just the X's
and I don't know I'm not sure not sure
whatever whatever we're doing right now
for assignment it should probably do but
no sorry event for the table not just
for your mother I understand that I'm
but what I'm saying is it's the same
thing it's an assignment right through
this temporary assignment which is what
it in fact is assignment is made so if
it works so I don't even know if
something like this will work if I say
that equals list list a B and this is so
scary I hate doing assignments you know
I I hate it oh my gosh what did that
just do well there's the answer for
everything else goes wrong
um
no but seriously if that were okay so
now try putting an extra level of list
around a
here enough what's gonna just set it
okay let's try it
uh I'm not 100% certain that it's gonna
do what you think it's gonna do I am
this is deep in the in the low level
nervous system of the animal yeah I did
the right thing okay I must have been
thinking of equal yeah I couldn't have
possibly done nothing different that is
so deep in the nervous system I mean I
remember when that was implemented in
like 1987 the it's been in there ever
since
okay it's all the complexion of our
users go ahead if we support this
doubles way which is what was also said
before then it will make somehow sense
again this notion of key arrows was
exactly yes I agree I agree this is very
close to that construct this table
things the thing that bugs me though is
the failure to return an association
when you give it an association as the
payload by the way I'm scared to even
try it should I try this there's a no
value what is this just gonna blow my
holes you might clear X&Y again I did I
thought you did one after okay
oh um I'm sure Talley just didn't get
around to that I think if you but they
think if you set it equal to list 1
comma 2 on the right hand side it will
set X&Y no way no way look what it just
said uh-huh
no way try it I'll try it and the other
way it's why I asked mr. it won't work
they'll hold it though there's something
else wrong but I think um let's see XY
he calls there's no way this is gonna
work is there is some some way where oh
I know what it is it's when you're when
you're doing part assignments that you
might yes that's that's correct part
assignment you can do yeah Association
thing okay so listen the thing that
we're realizing here which is highly
interesting is you know wherever an
assignment would work so I mean there is
an argument about whether this should
work I think there's a small argument
that this should work
okay if that works
then I all and weird here is that you
did you specify values on the left hand
side the X&Y
kind of
yeah and I don't know what this
evaluation semantics is for this how the
El Valle works they're in so in
JavaScript there is a similar syntax and
what they do is basically they have an
object that just has the keys so in our
world that would be
you're just a comma B in the Association
the limiters what that's weird
yeah I mean we can get the keys
obviously but I mean I'm totally
confused by that I mean it makes the
most sense in terms of you know what you
want you you want to extract a and B
from the Association right well hey
that's how you do that like this but you
want to extract it you want to extract
them from the right hand side I think
John is talking about creating an
association but this is really about
assigning today to the values the values
of needed session equals some
Association what do we do with the keys
what if the keys are present values or
our values in their right hand side and
I also want to assign the a and B to
somebody will be very confusing right
right right right right okay so listen
listen one thing that I think is clearly
desirable is the list based thing that
is precisely mirrors the assignment
that's been working for 33 years right
to be able to do that in table and width
seems highly worthwhile okay so there
are two things still on the table
one is Sanders syntax for table with
KITT caiera valley K ROV
which I don't think is totally crazy
however it will return a list it would
return a list and and it would also work
in the case of salmon things like this
that would just just work everywhere as
ultimate construct um
I think both things are the same thing
so each of these constructors table is
associated to list some is associated to
place etc so if we want a new
constructor that returns Association
sure yeah any name I suited thing well
we could have an association table just
for associations index associated with
the body no association table would be
it's it's actually pointless because
table the whole point of table is it
defines an iterator spec that is you
know based on you know Z the integers
type thing you know conceptually that
right it's like a range I was thinking
you would just take an association it's
fine but that's where I think we should
be I think we should be looking at a
construct like this which I think will
become a very common elementary
programming construct okay because it
avoids the need to use I mean I know we
we don't in fact need to use map because
of the table thing but that's somewhat
obscure so the question is what is the
best name if you're going to explain to
somebody what it does I keep looking at
that and I keep thinking it wants to be
an operator or whatever we're calling
them curried form yes
that's even weirder that's even
especially with you necessarily hold
semantics right because I mean what
would that actually look like it would
be okay
independent of the can't work problem
it's impossible but let's discuss it
anyway Stephen yeah Stephen I would like
to point out that we're way over time
we're having fun I know that this is and
this is important this for each
construct or something like it is
important well then we can it can be the
first item and on the next meeting I
[Music]
think Sandra just reinvented function
yes yes that's basically for each I
exper list nope I know what that is
that's map right for each I Expo
function of list is the same thing as
map function I Expo
if I'm not mistaken or its function with
an implicit list or attribute or uses
replace also so so you can you replace I
lay expression and also apply to the
list
we replace lists
operator right so what are you
suggesting replace I rule a inspiration
oh gosh yes
that's horrifying I mean it's rule delay
you need to do this at level one right
right you will need to map of Guelph and
a better version of that is the very
beautiful underused thing of this kind
that's a function right I was just
wondering if we should just emphasize
that more other than probably people to
C's in places and whatnot but people
will type it wrong beautiful um although
I personally am happy with the use that
we're making of rule okay let's I'm
sorry just one more iteration of the
saturator so to speak so the issue is
we've got variable here
that's iterating over list here
I wonder whether there's anything like
each value because we'd really like to
be able to do expert I list
okay see we've got to have a name that
makes it obvious what the argument order
is I don't think we can justify that
order no but if you swap the last two
you almost could and either of those two
it can be hold rest
yeah I'm not concerned about the holding
for that case um I mean think about that
what that would look like it would say
each element ABC for each element of ABC
I mean it ends up being very close to
you know the cases syntax but without no
patterns or arrows yeah
I see and you're saying without patterns
I mean at this again it's sort of
pattern it's like a replace as you were
saying it's like a replace all like an
unpatented place all what a weird
construct I goes to I squared where but
for well well but it really is in wait I
was going to say think it's a replace at
level one but it is yes you need to
specify the level um which chain is
probably a reason then that you sort of
it benefit from tying the iterator
variable I to the list in some form
right I mean cuz it's like suppose you
had that replaced syntax as something
that worked there may be that extra that
one that one does not okay that one does
work but suppose you had some other you
know function name that took something
similar to that and instead of the list
ABC you had a matrix you know it needs
to be something that's clear that it's
not going full depth into the structure
and replacing things
Isis stupid I mean it's a stupid to have
that because that's so unbelievably
close to table it's just like who cares
so the only real thing in the current
proposal that we cannot do here is
return an association from this which
you can always use Association at table
what do you mean so you cannot play
association to the whole table so your
expression is key goes whatever and then
you yeah I see you're saying you say
table I goes to I squared I goes to four
and then you just say Association of
that yeah yeah but that's a different
thing that's solving a different problem
I mean that's that's then you've got the
rather bizarre construct like this to do
that right but if we support it he goes
to rule right you could create whatever
you could do the same thing and then the
question is I mean what do we gain by
having something that directly returns
the Association which maybe we do but it
can't be in table no I understand I
understand I agree with that claim yes
the obvious name for that would be like
associates oh we have an Associated
don't we it doesn't have as far as I can
tell no we have associate to and things
like that we have don't we we have from
yeah those are called it's the it's a
it's a it's a
it's an l-value it's a thing like a pen
- hey great I think this would be
association table because it's two table
water smartest map
again I see it as it would be
association table yes but it's a goofy
goofy thing because it's got its
festooned and list syntax here just to
get something rather trivial out again
lowly I mean but you know if we are you
know have something where we generalize
you know the forms of iterators then I
like Jose's comment that you know some
is two plus as product is two times as
table is list as you know and they all
take the same discrete platters to
graphics yes you know sorts of specs you
just have you know a function and its
output type I understand so I mean you
could in principle have Association
table or some such other thing although
I claim that's not going to be terribly
useful most of the time because most of
the time this is not a you know the 1
goes to 2 goes to 3 goes to isn't a very
useful thing okay listen we should wrap
here we've got as far as I'm concerned
the Challenger so I mean we have come to
some conclusions about things we would
like to do about these destructuring
things which I think a really worthwhile
for both iterators and width but but the
the thing that remains open is the
brilliant name for this thing with
arguments in some order yeah yeah ok
thanks all see you later bye